we're going to go ahead and start
welcome you all again my name is DITA
Bhargava and on behalf of beacon and
Maine I would like to thank everyone for
being here tonight we are delighted that
we could bring you this very important
discussion with our incredible panelists
Thank You panelists for making out the
time and your busy schedules for joining
us today in a very special thanks to
Yael McMillan Center for sponsoring this
event our organization beacon and Maine
started out as an online community of
diverse socioeconomic backgrounds across
the state of Connecticut that shared a
common desire to protect and strengthen
our democracy our democratic values and
our democratic institutions we are
community of individuals that felt
compelled to protect the civic legal and
economic progress we have made as a
country over many decades my co-founders
Juliana has who's the CEO of beacon and
made Erica Rogovin burned Kate Hamilton
Moser
Tamara Wilcox and ard Simone along with
other partners in a wonderful group of
volunteers launched speaking in Maine we
have engaged an online community of over
10,000 people statewide to press forward
common ideals of equality mutual respect
and personal freedoms beacon and Maine
is a forward-looking organization whose
mission is to illuminate economic
strategies for the common good
we believe that bold policies will
advance the well-being of our diverse
communities and ensure a healthy
environment conducive to positive
economic development thank you all again
for making our inaugural event an
auspicious one I would like to give you
a brief introduction to our panelists
and then we will move right into our
discussion Governor Dannel Malloy began
his second term as governor of
Connecticut in January of 2015
later that fall extremists carried out a
series of coordinated violent terrorist
attacks in Paris France
the attacks inflamed public fears of
terrorism in the US and sparked a wave
of anti-refugee and anti-muslim
proposals by local state and national
politicians more than half of the
nation's governors declare that in the
current security climate
Syrian refugees would not be welcomed in
their states governor malloy could have
chosen the politically expedient course
and remain silent on a highly charged
controversial issue of refugee
resettlement and national security
instead just three days after the Paris
attacks and in a direct challenge to
those calling for the u.s. to close the
doors on Syrian refugees Governor Malloy
announced that Connecticut would
continue to accept refugees from Syria
and he has kept that promise in 2016
Governor Malloy received the John F
Kennedy Profile in Courage Award for his
defence of the u.s. resettlement of
Syrian refugees welcome Governor Malloy
[Applause]
Rebecca Heller is a visiting clinical
lecture at in Yale at law at Yale Law
School she graduated from Yale Law
School in 2010 and received her BA from
Dartmouth College she found it in
directs the international refugee
assistant project also known as irath at
Yale Law School an organization that
assists refugees and applying for
resettlement from abroad and adjusting
to life in the United States and she
launched subsequent chapters at UC
Berkeley Columbia Stanford and NYU Law
School's her student internships
included working in the immigration unit
of the New York Legal Aid Society and in
the worker and immigrant rights advocacy
clinic I wrap has helped to resettle
over 3,200 refugees and their families
to 14 different countries with an 85
percent success rate in resettlement
cases welcome Becka
Justin Cox is a staff attorney for the
National Immigration Law Center and ILC
and ILC is a leading US organization
dedicated exclusively to defending and
advancing the rights of low-income
immigrants their work has helped inform
innovative policy solutions to address
immigrants access to healthcare workers
rights and legal status for immigrant
youth Justin has litigated cases
involving unlawful immigration raids
unconstitutional and anti immigrant
state laws and is currently involved in
legal action against President Donald
Trump's Muslim ban executive orders
prior to joining an ayah and ILC Cox was
a staff attorney with the ACLU
immigrants rights project welcome to
[Applause]
speak Mubarak is a professor of
economics at the Yale School of
Management he is a development economist
with interests in environmental issues
professor Mubarak conducts field
experiments exploring ways to induce
people in developing countries to adopt
technologies or behaviors that are
likely to be welfare improving his
ongoing research projects are in
Bangladesh Brazil Chile India Kenya
Nepal and Malawi his research has been
published in journals across disciplines
including econometrics science the
review of economic studies the American
Political Science Review and demography
and covered by the New York Times The
Economist science and PR wired.com The
Times of London and other media outlets
around the world professor Mubarak is
currently working on research which will
highlight the economic impact of
immigration to our society
welcome professor Mubarak
Chris George has been the executive
director of integrated refugee and
immigrant services for the past 12 years
a New Haven based refugee resettlement
agency that welcomed 530 refugees to
Connecticut last year chris has spent
most of his professional life living in
or working on the Middle East before
returning to Connecticut in 2004 he
worked 7 years in the West Bank and Gaza
Strip Chris directed a legislative
strengthening project with the
Palestinian Parliament and later
established an emergency assistance
program for Palestinian nonprofits from
1994 to 1996 Chris was executive
director of Human Rights Watch Middle
East prior to that he worked with Save
the Children for nine years
mostly in the West Bank in Gaza in three
years with American Friends Service
Committee mostly in Lebanon Chris began
his international career in 1977 as a
Peace Corps volunteer in Muscat Oman
altogether he spent more than 16 years
living in the Middle East
learning and fluently speaking in Arabic
welcome Chris last but certainly not
least
Bushra Mehdi came to the United States
as a refugee from Iraq in 2014 along
with her husband Shakir and their four
children which were operated her own
business as a clothing designer in
Baghdad before she and her family were
forced to flee to Jordan after arriving
in the u.s. learning English became
bushroe's focus as she worked with New
Haven tailors and designers until
opening her own business again butcher
designs and becoming an active
contributor to Connecticut's economy
welcomed Bushra
[Applause]
all right we're going to jump right into
our question and the first one goes to
you governor Malloy
I would like to read you a recent quote
from Jeffrey Sachs who is the director
of the Earth Institute at Columbia
University a senior UN adviser he said
right now everyone is saying we don't
want these refugees we're not returning
them to the war zone perhaps but stay
out of our country but it can add up to
the very very much the same thing so the
international system is almost without a
system right now it's everybody on their
own it's very dangerous
we do have international agreements and
commitments we have the Geneva
Convention and we have responsibilities
and the United States which has been a
party to Middle Eastern Wars and
politics and as part of this Syrian
reality and the Syrian story has a legal
as well as moral obligation to take in
more refugees in 2016 Connecticut
welcomed almost a thousand refugees into
our state double the number settled in
2015 at least a hundred of those
refugees are from Syria can you tell us
why your administration chose to receive
more refugees and how the state supports
them socially and financially well first
let me just say I'm very happy to be
participating in this panel the folks
who were introduced after me have been
much more on the front lines of this
issue than I have I just wanted to make
it very clear after 30 governors had
said they would close their states or 31
to certain refugees that Connecticut was
not one of those states and that we
would be welcoming and then point of
fact between October 1st 2015 September
2016 we placed over 819 refugees 341 of
those were from Syria 46 from Iraq and
other countries obviously were a major
part of that and from October 1st 2016
through May of this year we've seen the
placement of three hundred and seven
nine refugees 134 of those are from
Syria and others from Afghan and Iraq
and elsewhere you know I I grew up in an
America that was chased after its
failures leading up to the second world
war the unforgivable act of turning away
refugees who had gotten themselves on a
ship and clearly should have been
welcomed in our country in other
countries and clearly our the time we
spent ignoring certain realities of what
was happening in Europe leading up to
the Second World War
should be sufficient warning for all of
us that we need to step forward on an
ongoing basis not an occasional basis
and stand for human rights a portion of
those rights are to find a new country
in which to say to live peacefully and
safely when you're no longer welcome in
your own country or cannot return to
that country and that certainly is well
documented by international agreements
going back to nineteen fifty one out of
disgust of our inability to have placed
refugees from Europe European war the
second world war and thanks to the good
work of the UN International agreement
was signed and we're partners and
signatories to that agreement and I
don't believe that any governor for that
matter or any may or any individual has
the right to refuse entry to any legal
immigration cludes refugees who by the
way are the most screened visitors to
our country and that's what they are for
one year and then they're required to
apply for their green card status and
most then apply for their citizenship
within the next five years after that
and with respect to the specific
question reality is in year one at least
most of the costs are reimbursed
or come to the United and come to the
receiving state and are then transferred
to the agencies that supply the support
there are those occasions when the state
will in the normal course as we would
with respect to any other visitor or
citizen of our country step in and
provide other services but with respect
to year one um you know most of that
that that cost is really associated to
the federal government not to the state
government after a refugee receives a
green card they're entitled to any other
service that any other individual in the
country is entitled to who has a green
card and whether they're receiving
support based on their economic
circumstances or health challenges or
not then then is shared potentially with
state government but even in those
programs and for for instance talking
about a medical emergency that was
reimbursable through Medicaid or
Medicare if the person was a senior
citizen those are largely federally
funded programs as well the the supposed
drain on state government just doesn't
exist now there are other requirements
obviously our United States Constitution
and our state constitution Connecticut
our state and our otherwise interpreted
to mean that we have to provide an
education to any child lives in our
country if you if you associate the cost
to that that is a cost that that society
takes on the reality is that most
refugees are women and children so there
are costs associated but that's a
fractional expense in any municipality
in which of refugee children would be
positioned particularly since most of
them live not all not exclusively but
but many of them I should probably say
live in large urban school districts so
we're talking about thousands of
children being affected by a very small
number of children with respect to those
expenses today extent that that is would
be very difficult
to break out so those are honest answers
to obvious questions and by way of
introduction Thank You Governor Malloy I
recently read on PBS that a city in New
York Utica have seen educated refugees
become a huge part of the labor force
that is actually halted the city's
economic decline contributing they
contribute economically culturally
enriched our communities would you say
in your experience of what the refugees
that Connecticut has brought in and
welcomed into our state that they've
been a net producers into our economy or
how much can you give us an idea as to
what that cost is on the on the taxpayer
well I I think that much of the
arguments many of the arguments made
against accepting refugees particularly
from certain countries are culturally or
religiously based forms of
discrimination but if you study the
countries that we are talking about
we're talking about people coming from
some of the hardest working societies in
the world Chris spent time with
Palestinians and Palestinian refugees
over the course of his professional life
you'd be hard-pressed to find people who
work harder than Palestinians under very
difficult circumstances so whether it's
an immediate return or or an eventual
return
I think immigrants and refugees have
been a net plus I can say that as
someone whose people emigrated from
Ireland beginning and while my
great-grandfather was born in Ireland in
1843 came to the United States and
fought two tours in the Civil War for
the for the Union I might add in
Connecticut so you know I think we are a
company a country of refugees I mean and
people seeking a second chance and I I
do I spent a lot of time and criminal
justice reform and
these are totally separate issues but
they have some similarities and I pretty
clearly talk about second chance Society
which is my efforts on the part of
criminal justice reform and point out
that unless you your people were brought
here in slavery or your Native American
everyone else's people came here first
for a second chance and that's true of
my people and it certainly is true of
our refugee population so we're a better
country because we had rounds of
refugees and rounds of people coming
from other countries and it really is
quite remarkable how American culture
probably is more inviting because it
bends itself to a greater extent to be
inviting great Thank You governor malloy
becca maybe you want to add to that and
then i want to come back to what i wrap
does and in sort of the vetting process
debt so yeah I mean as a Jew like my
family is here on something like our
57th chance and so we're really grateful
for you know America's place in the end
of the refugee Diaspora and but you know
I think all cultural assumptions aside
the in terms of like refugees ability to
contribute to communities that's
important to keep in mind that refugees
in addition to being extremely vetted
are are self selecting and the
definition of a refugee is someone who's
been basically severely persecuted in
their home country and who have gotten
out you're not a refugee technically
until you cross an international border
and having worked with thousands of
refugees let me tell you it requires
really really hard work to go through
the kinds of persecution that people go
through and then navigate your way
across a border through this like crazy
bureaucratic system to get to the US and
it you really have to be honestly like a
like a self-starter and you have to be
incredibly tenacious and work incredibly
hard so I think like regardless of what
what your country of origin is or what
your nationality is like the incredible
self selection process that it takes to
even like navigate this whole
geopolitical process in the first place
really ensures
the people who actually make it here you
know for lack of a better word like have
gumption and the other thing that I
thought was really interesting and you
know there's all these lawsuits going on
right now that you guys may have heard
about and a woman named Vivian Yee who
is a graduate of this university and
just joined the immigration desk at the
New York Times went out to write a story
about sort of who are the plaintiffs
behind these lawsuits and I think our
angle on the story and which is what I
think a lot of people are angling on
about refugees in pop culture which I
don't love is this sort of like refugees
they're just like us right this idea
that like we see refugees as the other
and the important thing is to humanize
them and say Oh refugees they go to the
gas station and they open bank accounts
and they send their kids to school um
and I would actually posit that refugees
are kind of better than us and because
they do all of that in spite of all the
things that they've gone through and
like how terribly difficult it is to
relocate here and she found something
really fascinating which was that when
she went to talk to the different
plaintiffs of the lawsuits I don't know
if any of you have ever been involved in
litigation and but it's really awful
people are really mean it goes on for
years like it can it can leave you very
aggrieved and you're sort of constantly
thinking about your injury right so you
would think that the refugees
participating in these Muslim banned
lawsuits would be very fixated on like
how discriminated they've been the
government has been to them and how the
US feels to them and what she found was
that almost all of the people she talked
to you said that she was like you know
you know tell me about why you're
participating in this lawsuit and they
were like oh my god it's so amazing I
live in a country where you can sue the
president hm
and I just I think you will like never
find a group of more patriotic people
than refugees because they know what a
lack of democracy looks like so I think
the value add to our society of bringing
these people in is just economic but
it's also like if you care at all about
like the American tradition which
allegedly the civil war was fought over
and will keep bringing in refugees and
Becka could you two walk us through the
process because I think no does it make
no sense at all no I'm just kidding I
walk because oh because out there people
think there is no process but in actual
it's a very very rigorous process so
when a refugee is identified registered
and vetted for resettlement in America
walk us through how difficult it is for
that refugee in Iraq or Syria or
wherever
how difficult is actually for them to
come to our country and it's so
difficult that I gave up a six-figure
salary offer to work at a public law
firm because I felt that the process was
so complicated that people needed
full-time lawyers to assist them with
with navigating it and you you know it's
the process usually takes three to five
years and we don't have that long and
but the synopsis is first you register
with the United Nations the UN is
allegedly screening you to see if
there's something really urgent about
your case and whether you need to be
referred for medical assistance whether
you're gay or survivor of trafficking so
you need to be referred for protection
or whether you should be referred for
resettlement and this immediately breaks
down for two reasons one is that the UN
is just dramatically underfunded and
that's about to get worse so they don't
actually have the resources to do
outreach to most of the most vulnerable
people and to is that referrals are
mutually exclusive so if you have a
protection need or a medical need you
can't simultaneously be referred for
resettlement which means that by
definition the most vulnerable people
tend to not be getting referred for
resettlement which has very few slots
available allegedly for the most
vulnerable and which started out and
funnily enough because the UN didn't
digitize their files so there was
literally only one folder per case and
they did the folder couldn't be in
multiple units at the same time but you
know the governor talked about how we we
formed these legal agreements and
starting in 1951 it took the u.s. until
1967 to join in but we got there and we
really have an update of the system
since then and if you get selected by
the UN which like one out of 30 people
will be and to get referred to the US
for resettlement you'll then go through
a minimum of three interviews there'll
be anywhere from one to seven hours long
you'll have to produce hundreds of
pieces of paperwork most of it won't
make sense and then there's something
that I think of as sort of the trauma
credibility paradox so the vast majority
of refugees that get rejected coming to
this country and actually get rejected
because the person interviewing them
doesn't believe them and that's because
what happens is that like something
really awful happens to you and then you
flee your house in the middle of the
night and if you're smart you don't
bring your documents right because you
don't want to get stopped and checked
and have someone find those documents
right the same way that like when we go
through JFK we have to delete all of our
social media accounts they don't be like
what we're actually saying about Customs
and Border Protection on so so most
refugees have no real physical evidence
of what happened to them which means
that the only thing that they have to
rely upon in these interviews is the
veracity of their own word and of course
that's something really traumatizing
happens to you you're probably going to
have some kind of post-traumatic stress
and the primary way that that's likely
to manifest is in an inability to recall
or discuss the precipitating event which
is the entire focus of the interview so
in this whole interview they're looking
for you to sort of become it's really
victimizing in a way because I think
that refugees are these people who have
been through this crazy stuff and have
survived and and then we're trying to
like shoehorn them and say like we've
had people rejected because they didn't
cry when they talked about something
really upsetting at their interview so
the person thought they were lying
because they were having an
inappropriate emotional reaction and
then simultaneously with all of this at
your being background checked by
something like 20 different intelligence
agencies like eight of which you know we
can't name because we'd have to kill you
against like numerous databases and you
go through every database twice and then
that's only good for 12 months so if the
process takes longer than 12 months you
go through the whole thing again then
you get our Yvette 'add a little bit by
the Office of refugee resettlement for
the US and then finally you get to get
on a plane when you have a TSA check and
then a checked by Customs and Border
Protection and so essentially and I know
you've made this point I've heard you
make it before that even though Muslim
bland Muslim ban 1.0 and listen ban 2.0
that they were rejected by the court
said essentially a Muslim ban 3.0 is
actually going on right now and the
vetting process is actually harder than
it was before this new president
office and has kind of put that notion
out there yeah I mean a lot of really
interesting statistics have come out
about the number of not just refugee but
also like disproportionate visa
rejections of people from predominantly
Muslim countries and I expect that to
get worse before it gets better
thank you Justin Anna and I Elsie is one
of the leading organizations in the u.s.
exclusively dedicated to defending and
advancing the rights of low-income
immigrants and refugees can you walk us
through the work that your organization
has done since the elections and how
proposed federal policy or the Muslim
ban will affect a state like Connecticut
we'll be doing a deeper dive into the
Supreme Court decision later but if you
could kind of give us an overview and
historical perspective on that'd be
great sure and backing up slightly from
well first thank you thank you for
inviting me in for being here I
appreciate everyone who's here wants to
learn about this topic it's great that
there's so much interest so backing up
slightly from the election let's say
from the campaign I was glad that the
Paris attacks in November of 2015 were
mentioned because that's really where
all of this started you know I've been
doing immigrants rights work since I was
in law school graduated from law school
here to us made and you know I in all
the work of all the immigrants Ward's
work that I that I did up until November
of 2015 I never worked with refugees
ever and most of us in the immigrants
rights world who do like sort of civil
rights for for immigrants most of us
didn't either because why would anyone
pick on refugees I just doesn't make any
sense right like they you know we always
have to fight this dichotomy of like
good refuge excuse me good immigrants
versus that bad immigrants like that's
like a common frame that is used
unfortunately in our political discourse
but no one ever doubted the refugees
were the good immigrants and so and so
they just weren't targets of the kind of
discrimination that we've seen in the
last couple of years until the Paris
attacks and until Donald Trump frankly
and you know if you look back at the at
his Twitter account as I have had to do
much more than I would like recently
can see in his public comments
everything else I mean he Donald Trump
was talking about Syrian refugees from
the summer of 2015 but it was really the
Paris attacks that sort of galvanized
that as a part of his campaign and his
call for you know a total and complete
shutdown of Muslims immigrants in United
States that occurred like two weeks
after the Paris attacks it's not a
coincidence and so when these 31
governors started you know saying that
they were going to turn away Syrian
refugees we of course started suing and
you know we'd been suing States for
discriminating against undocumented
folks for years I have to say that when
they started discriminating against
Syrian refugees like the easiest
lawsuits that we've ever had to put
together I mean it's just crystal clear
you don't even have to explain why you
like that you know just because they're
undocumented it doesn't mean they don't
have rights no none of that it was like
they're you know they're lawfully
present they're refugees what are you
doing this is discriminating against
them on the basis of national origin and
their immigration status both of which
states are not allowed to do and you
know the lawsuits are relatively easy on
the merits legally sometimes getting
them off the ground was a little
difficult because I remember so I live
in Atlanta and you know the Georgia
governor was one of the first to to do
this and I went and met with the Syrian
refugee family you know to talk to them
about all of this and you know we're
talking about filing a lawsuit and and
the question I got was won't the
governor like send his men to beat us up
and and I never actually had that
question from a client before um and so
you know that but that was you know
that's where they're coming from that's
the sort of that was the first question
that they had and at any rate you know
thankfully the courts shut down the
state's attempt to discriminate against
Syrian refugees relatively quickly Texas
Alabama Indiana none of them were able
to get away with it at all but then of
course we had the election and and
Donald Trump immediately continued what
the states had already started tried to
start and so so since then you know I
don't want won't get into a deep dive
into the
litigation yet but you know soon as the
election happened and we got over a
shock we immediately started thinking
like okay what's this Muslim band going
to look like you know that's been
promised so what's going to look like
and we thought it was going to look
actually a lot like a program called in
Sears which was a registration program
that was instituted after 9/11 that you
know prevented no terrorist attacks
caught no terrorist but did you know
sweep up a lot of Muslim immigrants who
were out of status or the like and so we
sort of anticipated to being something
like that and then of course after the
inauguration that first week various
versions of what became the Muslim ban
were released and we started gearing up
and you know we were going to pursue to
challenge it when everything blew up in
the airports and we've got sidetracked a
little bit on that kind of litigation
with with I wrapped but the long and
short of it is that you know the first
the first Muslim ban we you know we were
involved in the airport litigation along
with I rap or Co counseling with them
and the ACLU and the the law schools
were current immigrants rights advocacy
clinic and then we filed the second case
which is now up at the Supreme Court
trump VI rap now and I can talk about
that a little more later great thank you
I'm going to jump over to Chris George
because I want to finish sort of the
resettlement process and then we're
going to go to you professor Mubarak so
we can talk about the economic impact
Chris your organization iris is
contracted by the State Department to
work with local groups to resettle and
integrate refugees families into our
communities what are you doing to make
sure that refugees successfully
integrate and how much money both state
and federal is spent on resettlement
sure so a little more on the structure
many of you might already know this but
there are 350 refugee resettlement I'm
going to call them entities refugee
resettlement age I call them entities
because those are the Supreme Court
decision that brilliantly we're all
entities now
[Laughter]
we ask all refugee resettlement agencies
iris so now is called an entity we're
all entity is we're we're all entities
we're all entities there are three
hundred three hundred and fifty refugee
resettlement agencies / entities spread
across the country three hundred and
fifty they're all connected to at least
one of nine national organizations
you're you've heard of many of them the
International Rescue Committee Catholic
Charities Church World Service and those
nine are all under the supervision
regulation of the State Department which
handles along with the Department of
Homeland Security the oversees selection
and the vetting process so it's a
public-private partnership probably the
most efficient public-private
partnership in the country the
government does the selection provides
regulations and standards does some
oversight provide some funding but the
hard work of actually welcoming and
resettling refugees is done by nonprofit
groups voluntary organizations refugees
are resettled in virtually every state
in the country there are three refugee
resettlement agencies in Connecticut one
is in Hartford Catholic Charities one is
in Bridgeport International Institute
and we're based here in New Haven and
our job is to welcome refugees and help
them get off to a good start
the overall objective is to help
refugees become self-sufficient
it is a struggle and it's supposed to be
a struggle the blueprint for today's
refugee resettlement program is the
American immigrant experience you've
heard some of your parents or
grandparents talk about we all crammed
into one bedroom we had to walk miles to
get a job first job was you know washing
dishes in the snow you know it was tough
and we had no money we came with nothing
I was you know a very successful
businessman overseas in my home country
but here I started at the bottom of the
ladder that is what most refugees go
through
we have very little money we get some
money from the federal government our
budgets roughly 2 million roughly half
of that is from the federal government
the other half we have to raise
privately no money from the state we get
actually something better than money
from our state government we get a
governor who welcomes with open arms
refugees from all over the world and
that's worth millions we get a community
like New Haven and the rest of
Connecticut which has stepped forward
even when refugee resettlement became
controversial even when others were
turning away even when our own president
was saying he wants to send Syrian
refugees home and not accept any new
refugees who are Muslim the more
controversial and negative stuff that
was said nationally people in
Connecticut stepped forward and said we
want to help you know how can we help
train us to resettle refugees and will
welcome a Syrian refugee into our
neighborhood a group of five synagogues
in the Greater New Haven area came
together almost immediately and said we
want to welcome Syrian Muslim refugees
into our neighborhoods show us how so we
had no choice but to ask Washington to
double the number of refugees we had
more offers of help than we had refugees
to accept it it's kind of a weird
situation to be in and we're almost
facing that now if the numbers begin to
dwindle we've got at least a dozen
community groups that are hoping to
resettle refugees and if we don't get
more assigned to us they'll be left
waiting so that's the structure what
does it cost well the total number from
beginning to end for the government is
probably about me journalists did some
research couple of years ago it comes to
about $17,000 per refugee all of the
government costs to send people overseas
to do the vetting process to pay them
danger pay
you know Dubai the computers to bring
them here to get them started with the
State Department welcome grant about
17,000 dollars per person to save their
lives that's why we do it after all
I mean sure they're an economic benefit
sure they're great soccer players sure
they're amazing dressmakers and
incredible cooks and they enrich our
communities and diversify us but in the
end we welcome refugees to save their
lives and that should be enough so the
costs are I think minimal I mean we
spend probably a total of about $4,000
per person to resettle the refugees that
we resettle here and and iris and we get
so much help from volunteers and and
community groups it is phenomenal I just
have to show a map all right so usually
my first 10 years on the job about 2
groups per year would step forward and
say hey iris
we want to welcome refugees show us how
to do it we want to be a community
co-sponsor two groups a year since
January of 2016 look at all the dots on
the map these are all community groups
all over the state that want to welcome
refugees 50 refugee families have been
placed with community groups so far in
Connecticut this should be happening all
over the country we need to convince
those 350 entities refugee resettlement
agencies that they can also do a program
like this and if we're successful we'll
be able to dramatically increase the
number of refugees coming to this
country and not only that behind every
dot are hundreds of volunteers who are
learning about the global refugee crisis
understanding the refugee resettlement
process getting a clear picture of what
vetting means
meeting real live refugees tutoring kids
in school walking them to the grocery
store helping them learn English helping
them understand their electricity bill
that is how you build support for
refugee resettlement if this were
happening in every state there'd be so
much pushback against what's going on in
Washington there'd be no need for a
conference like this
no offense thank you Chris and so you
know what you've highlighted is that at
a minimal cost helping refugees is the
right thing to do I'm going to move on
to Professor Mubarak now and who will
help us highlight that it's actually the
smart thing to do as well I just want to
first tell you about a recent study of
refugees living in Cleveland Ohio that I
read about and in that area they found
found that the fiscal impact of refugees
was an estimated 2.7 million dollars in
tax revenue and a total economic benefit
of 48 million dollars in 2012 alone
and between 2002 and 2012 refugees
served started 38 businesses that
employed 141 locals in the Cleveland
area so so that's where in this little
town we found that it's also smart thing
to do and I imagine that's kind of the
case all the way around I'm going to
first play a very quick video I know
we're posting on time a very quick video
that Professor Bob Eric has put together
and then he's going to talk about his
research behind this
[Music]
I'm mushrik Mubarak and I'm a professor
of economics at the Yale School of
Management I want to tell you about the
logic behind the economic benefits of
migration and outline six ideas that
come out of the empirical research on
this subject each of these points is
backed up by rigorous studies here's how
a lot of people think about immigration
a migrant worker comes in and takes a
job away from a native worker there are
a lot of mistakes in this picture
according to the economists with study
language of course the story would be
that simple only is an immigrant
substitute for a native worker perfectly
in reality migrants often take jobs
natives don't want and immigrants are
more likely to move into sectors where
language skills and customer or client
facing skills are not as important in
other words natives with such fields are
not easily displaced in the case of
Agriculture for instance migrant workers
literally keep boots from rotting on the
ground
in some cases migrant labor can even be
a complement to native that's an
economist way of saying that migration
can create more jobs than existed before
picture a busy restaurant orders flying
into the kitchen and dishes flying out
the diners and then back to the same now
imagine migrant labor makes it easier
for the business owner to find cheap
dishwashers business is better it
expands and brings in more waiters and
managers think about this there 168
hours in each weeks and you have a
certain number of things you just have
to get them you have to work care for
your children mow the lawn maintain your
parents home what would you do if
someone took one of those chores off
your hands okay you might just play more
PlayStation but not everyone is like
that many migrants provide services like
lawn mowing and babysitting lowering
those costs and seeing time for workers
to be more productive
[Music]
here's another important point
innovation makes our economy grow highly
skilled migrants create scientific
breakthroughs and other improvements
foreign-born scientists and engineers
rather than the u.s. create many of
these innovations the typical Nobel
Prize winner is affiliated with the u.s.
University but was not born in the
United States these innovations result
in new products and markets most new
jobs are created by new and growing
businesses who create the businesses
that create these jobs here are just a
few of the companies that were founded
by immigrants for us you might have
heard of some of them
[Music]
this fact isn't so surprising if you
think about who immigrants are leave
their home to strike out for a distant
land someone with ambition and gumption
and who can successfully navigate all
the challenges such a move someone with
intelligence and grit
again the economists have interpreted
all selectivity while immigration will
certainly create challenges for some
individuals the research is clear that
overall the drives economic growth and
creates more winners and losers in the
receiving country that video to my eight
and seven year old and they loved it as
well as it's a video for everyone so
professor Mubarak if you can expand on
that video what your research is showing
and any focusing on the economic impact
sure um I'll try my best to just talk
about topics and ideas and results that
are based on rigorous studies with large
sample data at the books relying on
anecdotes however before I get into that
though I do want to well thank you for
organizing and for moderating thank all
the panelists for being here it's a
great opportunity for us for many of my
students who are here and I want to
thank Governor Malloy for taking a very
brave stance as a former immigrants
myself or from not a very long time so
and deeply appreciative of the stance
you've taken and all the work all the
fantastic work that the other panelists
are doing
I immigrated here from a very poor
country Bangladesh my wife emigrated
from very poor family she's from the
Cayman Islands and I remember this is
anecdote part this is not a large sample
Sita I just recently just last week at a
conversation DC with a friend from
graduate school so we had gotten married
when we were undergrad we arrived at
graduate school so I was getting a PhD
and she was getting a master's degree
and and a friend wanted to borrow a
hundred dollars and then I realized I
literally didn't have that I I don't
have the same set of challenges that
refugees have have to go through I'm not
trying to equate that situation right
but you know ma immigrants who come to
this country are as you as you were
saying better very positively selected I
think we we pre organize this with the
Ganga yes it's an unusual word to use
for it to come up price now my huge fan
I've been watching this video on Reba
okay and then you know so now you know
it's been 15 20 years and now you know
we're providing sort of thanks to this
great country this great state we're
providing maybe an aisle can I borrow a
hundred dollars as it turns out now I
don't have the experience lawyer tell me
a pretty girl so it'll balance the
budget
your only offer hundred dollars you know
my children have a thousand times the
opportunity and hopefully they'll go on
they'll go on to do greater things and
then we did so for example my daughter I
guess two years ago at the time she was
10 she organized this huge drive and
talked to iris and from her school and
friends they they you know iris had some
needs for alarm clocks and blankets
etcetera like salvia staff mentioned and
and for the last year or year our year
and a half there's been boxes and boxes
of alarm clocks and blankets under
material sitting in my sitting in my
garage and she was a little frustrating
that I did all this work but they don't
want it and then I was like that's a
great problem to have because you know
the ayah says we don't know I really
responsible look we already have enough
because
you totally just got someone measured we
need more refugees logs I'd like it I
mean that's and I'm and I'm thinking you
know what a great state what a great
organization that we've been able to
mobilize that many resources we're
actually in excess now we're we're very
lucky to be living here okay so now
going to the hard data so all of the
points I made in that video were were
only based on studies that have very
rigorous large sample data with very
good research techniques behind them and
so let me tell you what the economics
research shows when you aggregate across
sort of five 600 or 700 studies that
have been done on the economic effects
of immigration so it's an important
topic and a policy issue that every ten
years or so the National Academy of
Sciences has convened a panel to look at
okay what do we know about this topic
about this policy topic as immigrant
immigration good or bad for the country
what are the costs what are the benefits
right and here's the sort of four bullet
point summaries sorry so one immigrate
immigrants don't seem to put much of a
downward pressure on native wages that
was the point I was making in the video
right
except if they do it seems to be
concentrated on previous generations of
immigrants because a new generation of
immigrants is the closest substitute for
somebody who came before but it's not as
easy for them to displace Americans who
may have local language skills you know
culture specific skills it's not as easy
for them to display some right so if
you're worried about you know previous
generations of people you should worry
about people like like me oh and then
we're the ones who are trying to like
close the door behind us and then on
economic growth the the results are
unequivocal that area so for example
states that have seen higher rates of
Amick in migration has higher rates of
economic growth then on entrepreneurship
on employment creation especially among
high-skilled immigrants these facts are
even stronger and much more positive and
not really subject to any academic
debate right if immigrants create a
disproportionate share of businesses in
the country there so for example about
15%
the labor force are not native-born
their foreign-born but about 20% 25% of
entrepreneurs are so they're much more
disproportionately more likely to be job
creators right and finally in terms of
fiscal costs so there is the the results
to show that in the first couple of
years immigrants take more out of the
system than they put in but if you take
a 10 to 15 year view that reverses right
immigrants are like revenues exceed
exceed the cost of the impulse right and
of course the National Academy of
Sciences put together this panel and I
want to talk about communication of this
research right and this panel like wrote
a very clear and nice executive summary
with these four points that I just
highlighted and then the right-wing
media covered it by saying like the US
National Academy of Sciences expert
panel says that immigration imposes a
500 billion dollar fiscal cost on the US
economy now was there read of that of
that report right that's not how the
Washington Post and New York Times
covered it they actually they were much
more responsible in that they just wrote
down what was in the executive summary
without further interpretation or
picking a choosing so I think it's
important for us to think about not just
you know what the research shows but how
do we effectively communicate it and in
how policy is made right because there's
a lot of things that get screwed up in
the middle right and finally let me take
the complementary position that Chris
took right but you'd imagine that we
don't care at all about the humanitarian
motors they're right we don't care about
saving lives right so is it a good idea
for us to allow refugees and immigrants
to come in okay I think on the economic
side the answer is for sure yeah that's
what the data show so even if you don't
care it might actually is a pretty good
idea okay now what are the but we also
you know we I don't want this to be an
echo chamber and we also have to be
aware of and worried about you know some
downside risks right so what are they
and you know so I'm I'm Muslim and so
this is a this is you know the security
risk and you know how my community is
perceived is something I think about and
worry about but of course I have this
a professional handicap that anytime I'm
even thinking about like what what is it
but my family is about like I always
just go to the data and think about like
what the data says right it's hard for
me to think without looking at data
right and so if you look at so there's a
lot of people who are worried about
immigrants coming and they worry about
like responses that Muslims have to
attitudinal surveys that are done around
the world right so sad you know surveys
are things like you know you're asking
large samples of people around the world
what do you think about people of a
different religion what do you think
about women's place in society right and
what what how they should behave in at
home what their responsibilities should
be what do you think about homosexuality
right and people have pointed out that
look Muslims men or people from Muslim
majority countries or Muslims themselves
because there are also religion
indicators and these in the surveys that
they express opinions that are just not
conducive to our culture right that
don't fit with our culture right and
okay so then when when people have made
this point and if you go on YouTube
you'll see lots of videos where people
are reporting this data right so then
the question for me was oh is it is that
really about religion or is it about
poverty or the place that people are
coming from so for example is it the
case that Christians and Nigeria
expressed opinions that are a lot better
than Muslims in Nigeria right or is it
the case that you know Pakistanis are
expressing opinions that are a lot worse
than Indians right so think about like
you know we should think about a control
group here that's that's the only case
that I'm making right that you know it's
even if you even if you're making the
case that Muslims are expressing their
opinions right we ought to be thinking
about are they expressing bad opinions
relative to people who have similar
socioeconomic characteristics or
something else that my driving it so is
it religion is the recount is it
economics is it education right what
what happens if you control for
education so it turns out these gaps you
know that people highlight that you know
Muslims express opinions about
homosexuals about women right that we
would find troublesome and if you you
know if you read the responses you would
find I think you would find the
Troublesome
okay now once you start controlling for
these other factors so is it you know so
I can ask the question our Nigerians
responding to these questions when
they're Christian versus Muslims I'm
holding constant that country they come
from right and I'm holding constant some
income level and education level and
turns out those gaps become narrower but
they do remain okay and the Jewish
people express opinions that I would say
you know liberals would find most
comforting right but both Christians and
Muslims in relative to that expressed
opinions that I think you would find
troublesome right and so we can't just
wash that away right and this is
something that we our community needs to
tackle right I also think about you know
people who are my kids are growing up in
a Muslim community with lots of
Bangladeshi friends and you know and I'm
looking closely at okay how are what are
parents
what are parents teaching their kids
okay and I think all you know it's not
like just like America is not
necessarily an exceptional place it just
happens to have been able to attract
exceptional people it's not like
Nigerian or bangladeshis or Indians that
they just because they're refugees that
they're exceptional people they're just
human being there's going to be a
distribution of people go then bad right
and there's they're gonna pull some
risks right and I and I do agree with
Chris that in spite of those risks I
think the right thing to do is to be
welcoming rights and to save lives but
we also have to be aware of and figure
out how to enact policies to tackle
those types of risks right so that
cultural assimilation happens and we
don't end up with more problems thank
you thank you professional rock bushra
very excited to hear about your story if
you could walk us through when you were
first vetted how long it took your
journey to Connecticut and and then your
journey to learn the language assimilate
and and start your own business yes
thank you for inviting me thank you for
being a glad need to all the people and
when I came here 2014 I didn't speak
English
I didn't know anyone but after four
months I am looking I am asked my
daughter this can't help me for any
address near us or like company for
sewing or designer or because I have
experience in Iraq 2002 20 25 years for
suing I want to like learn something for
suing for matter she give me a dress I'm
go I want to the honor for vestibular
ahem hi my name is Misha I want I'm
looking for a job I don't speak English
well I'm training and he told me okay
and can you come when Monday
I want Monday and he saw my work
he gave me internships I'm very happy
about that
after that he gives me full job for job
and then starts job I'm very happy
because I want to learn the word in
English for showing like super button I
know everything in Arabic I think you
measure is going to enjoy I don't care
the lawyer behind I can't I don't care
about money because I want to know and I
want to know the word in English for my
job I start to work with them with him
and after that I get I got their second
job what they were surprised because I
want to make my language strong after
that after work one year and a half I
think I start to think about my own
business I told iris about that
please can help me because I want to
open my own business I just have me for
now put my credit my business cards in
the office and also give me machine and
a stitch machine and I start by about
table and the iron steam iron and after
2 years
I start off in my own business called
wishlist fashion and to employ people in
your business are there other workers
yes yes yes great oh yeah just read your
dress yeah no this is a gift my husband
and Butch Arquette now I've customized I
can I speak English yes okay great
can you tell us a little bit about your
life in Iraq when you were forced to
leave Iraq and and how long it took you
to come to the United States what what
what sort of the process was for you to
be here in Iraq I have my own
dressmaking business my husband and he
was accountant 27 years in Iraq my
children and we're in the school and
when my son of the son he gets a job
with the US a military contractor and
somebody don't like that every time ask
me ask us why we accept our son work
with the American people I don't care
about that the first time because my son
he wasn't he wasn't doing anything wrong
only his work after that my gum and then
my husband got shot this is reason
because my son work and this is mean I
should leave Iraq and we decided
levira go to Jordan live in Jordan one
year and a half but you asked me about
the meeting was meeting my our vetting
versus start in Iraq because my son when
he applied for work with them you have
us a military contractor and he weighed
like 11 months before he worked
within I remember he give me like this
favor more Dever information for me for
my husband for my family for sister
brother all of my dad my grandma my
grandma light need information and need
the information for my friend five years
before like that and when I moved to a
Jordan the start same saying the
question same information asked about my
family my husband's family for my friend
what what do you work in Iraq well they
give me the address before for more more
information for all my family and stay
like one year and a half after that I
got a call from two and date for travel
I came here to fall 9 April 2014
ok I was happy when how shall we say
[Applause]
good great well thank you everyone for
for the fantastic input and shedding
light on our on this issue I'd like to
now take the questions to our audience
and government law I'm going to start
with you and take a couple of questions
I know that that you're a little bit of
a time crunch
um government what's the risk federal
government could force Connecticut to
stop accepting refugees I don't think
there's any I don't think there's any
legal basis for the federal government
to do that they're not violating any law
we're not I I suppose if if if if the
Congress was to enact a law that gave
that power to the executive branch to
enforce and it was stood a a challenge
you know then things could change but I
just I you know
just because we have a blusterer in
chief doesn't mean that our Constitution
is going to be violated in that in that
way and do you have any thought on the
recent Supreme Court decision for the
well they've decided to wait until the
fall to really hear the entire case but
that they are not letting refugees in
you talked a little bit about CEQA or
you will talk about this but do you have
any thought about how we can protect
Connecticut from that particular vetting
process where certain folks who are not
tied to individuals and I'm not sure how
tied what tied means exactly that
they're not being allowed to come to our
borders well you know I think this is an
area where Connecticut has demonstrated
leadership and educational institutions
in Connecticut have demonstrated
leadership colleges and universities
have gone out of their way to be open to
students from across the world and and I
think have made a special effort to make
sure that potential students from the
countries that that the president had
identified are reached out to and
otherwise feel welcome and I do believe
that eye contact with University may may
ultimately be to meet the description
that was in this very short language
that was used by the court I think this
refugee issue as an entity these
organizations so I think that there's
room in the rather short of decision or
announcement of the court on the other
hand we can't ignore that three justices
have said that they would enforce the
law in its entirety without any
limitation so that's a that's a scary
thought so they're already at three they
need to get to five is that hard or not
due to the right justices live long
enough for this case to be decided
when it's heard after its heard in
October so I you know I think it's up in
the air but I do see it positive and
that this concept that people who have
relationships or relatives or contact
with with the country should not be
denied access I think that's the one
bright spot of the decision and if
that's if that's open on a question for
all of the remaining members of the
court as opposed to these three who went
out of their way to express themselves
and there's reason for hope but you know
we've been disappointed in elections
we've been disappointed in court cases
we you know we live a life of of some
gains and some setbacks and the question
for governor malloy tell us about how
Connecticut state partners with
nonprofits I know I think Christmas book
a little bit about this to settle with
refugees economically and legally
speaking well I mean I think you know
our role is one of at least I envision
it as one of leadership and
communication you know when when I when
I took the step that we took we made a
point of communicating to our
municipalities and to our Boards of
Education we have communicated with
Boards of Education on ongoing basis
with respect to their responsibility I
can tell you that I have not personally
been contacted by any board of education
official in any local community who said
that they don't want to honor the work
that others are doing and their legal
obligations so I think we play a
leadership role we have had discussions
with with the three agencies in the
state about ways that we can play a role
some of that is financial not directly
to the agencies but directly to the
person in some cases providing a service
or receiving a service but but by and
large Chris and his colleagues take the
brunt of that work but but there is a
cost you know and
and whether it's 17,000 on average or
more in a more expensive place I can't
you know I don't have the data on it
there is a cost but there's a game and
you know there's precious few in this
audience who can't trace their roots to
some other country question that I
actually don't know the answer to I know
that um when refugees get assigned to
resettlement agencies you get like a few
weeks notice typically but the number by
state does that get decided at the
beginning of the fiscal year yes there's
a state refugee coordinator based in the
Department of Social Services who has to
approve the numbers that the three
refugee resettlement agencies give him
at the start of the year and does the
state consider itself an entities yeah
sure we are an entity I can I can say
definitively we are an entity so in your
official capacity in my official
capacity you need to explain to people
in the audience who are aware why we
keep using the e word you started it I
kind of feel like you should have to
explain the Supreme Court ruling has
said that refugees will be allowed to
enter the United States if they can
demonstrate they have a bona fide
relationship with an individual or an
entity in this country and lawyers are
burning the midnight oil trying to
figure out what entity means I hear
tomorrow we might get a ruling from the
government we feel that refugees have
relationships with us long before they
actually arrive so we feel that that we
should be considered an entity and
therefore 110,000 refugees should come
this fiscal year so what I'm playing
with is that hypothetically
some like if Connecticut took us out if
you want to take a thousand refugees
next year and you do those negotiations
before the federal fiscal year
starts then ostensibly there's a
thousand refugees that have a
relationship with Connecticut I think
you're you've gone a step too far if
there's usually Trevor yeah it's a good
try no I think I think that that would
only be true to the extent in an actual
file has been opened and a relationship
established you can't establish a
relationship with a number you can
establish relationship with an
individual and I would agree that if
that that relationship is established
between an agency and an individual
there's no doubt that in my mind that
the agency is an entity so humor me for
just 30 more seconds let's say that
there's an in I'm a lawyer - okay you're
not no no no no let's say that there is
an NGO that identified 600 refugees at
the beginning of the fiscal year and
sent files on them to Connecticut and
then and then the resettlement agency
could request those 600 files right at
these weird NFL draft refugee meetings
so then hypothetically it's not just a
number anymore it's like an actual
person yeah III think that that that is
at the very least the initial step of
establishing an actual relationship I
think then the courts would say well has
there been communication of that
relationship how do you have a
relationship with someone that you
haven't had a communication with so I
mean I think there are other logical
steps but I think the premise that
you're driving is that if those
relationships can be constituted
identified constituted and action taken
then then there's reason to believe that
under any reasonable interpretation of
what an entity is or relationship is
that that person would be safe I also
think that's true of somebody who's
received treatment at a hospital or
someone who's being educated at an
institution you know you should ask what
does that mean if you have a
relationship if if that if the education
is taking place over the Internet that
would be an interesting question but
but I think that those are those are
very real questions and ones that I the
one reason I take some level of hope is
that only three justices said that they
would enforce the law as written and the
rest of at least are open to some
redefinition so one of the questions
from our audience was will refugee
organizations count as the bona fide
connection to the United States and what
I'm hearing is no it wouldn't air we
have still yet to that's a it's a
resounding yes yeah we are entities yes
it's a relationship with relationships
so we got bushroe's file biographical
information about her and her entire
family months prior she came here and I
think will argue that at that point at
least we've got a relation you have a
relationship with an entity what great
okay question for Becca or anybody else
who wants to answer this how are
refugees and immigrants placing jobs how
well are they matched at work that they
have experience with or work that they
consider to be fulfilling in system of
Arkham you want to add to this pickle
maybe yeah that's a question for that
okay the panel and create Chris I want
it how are refugees placed in job right
and how are they matched up with the the
talent that they may come to our state
with how the job their first job in
particular matches up with the town
right what's the proper in actually
finding a job well I've got at least one
staff member in the audience who Danny
who works with refugees and helping them
learn English and find jobs in the two
are intertwined very closely the biggest
obstacle that refugees have to getting
work any kind of work especially work
that at the level of what they were used
to doing in their home country is
language they don't speak English we
have welcomed physics professors from
the University of Baghdad who had very
good lives in
that that they didn't speak a word of
English their only job opportunities
initially we're cleaning hotel rooms
working in the back of restaurants maybe
working in small factories it is a shock
to people like that but with Thunder
Danny's instruction they learn English
quickly and and some can you know
hopefully get something that's a little
little higher but that's the immigrant
experience yeah and every now and then
we'll get someone who is very
accomplished in their home country and
does have some English and they will
move into jobs much closer
I mean buscher is an example of someone
who has been able to do because because
her job has not required a high level of
English fluency she was able to jump
into something fairly soon after you
arrived that's similar to what you were
doing in Iraq and my husband he has
experience for an auto mechanic
Hassan coming 27 years in your at I have
much hair and because he didn't speak
English he starts work at mechanic this
is okay okay no and he's an excellent
mechanic he fixed my Jeep he did a
better job on my Jeep than another auto
mechanic who's worked here 40 years and
he was sure the PLN sorry sorry no I
encouraged him and he study hard he
wanted he wants get license for drive
truck CDL CDL with me a truck
yes driver truck system and this he plus
the second test now he study hard about
said test for grades and does he ever
plan to once he has sort of has working
knowledge of English does he ever
planned to go back to accounting work or
he's he's happy with don't make more
money as a truck driver
not always that money all right I'm
going to ask one more question and then
we're going to move on to the second
part of our evening here what resources
websites etc can we use to share this
information with people who are
skeptical about the benefit of refugees
in Connecticut well Chris's agency has a
great site to go and understand you
should yeah it you know and I'm the only
London thank you for organizing this
conference I apologize thank you I mean
this is what it's about it it's about
education educating people about
refugees refugee resettlement we cannot
expect people in this country to support
the refugee resettlement program if they
don't understand it and we can't you
know blame them for not understanding it
it's our own fault
refuge 350 refugee resettlement agencies
we are pathetically behind in educating
people very few refugee resettlement
agencies do outreach in public education
and and participate in forums like this
we need to catch up and do more of that
so yes jump on our website that will
lead you to a host of other websites
where you can learn about it organize
public forums organize receptions in
your homes any group you're part of
invite a refugee resettlement person to
come and speak there we have got to
spread the word so can I get a promise
now from all of you that if we do
another one like this that y'all show up
in his great well let me just tell you
one other story I you know a couple of
weeks after 31 governors had signed on
to block of refugees from coming to
their states I was on a phone a
telephone conference call and it was
painfully obvious even weeks after they
had taken the stand how little the
governors themselves understood about
the process and they just had not taken
the time or immersed themselves in the
subject before they signed on to this
Challenge that was basically laid down
by the governor of Michigan of all
states and in the intervening weeks with
all of the controversy that that was
around it they didn't bother to
understand the screening process and so
I'm I'm on the phone listening to the
Secretary of Homeland to trying to
explain to these governors what the
process was so there's this thing about
you know vetting these are the most
vetted visitors to the United States and
as I said on that conference call and
one reason that some governors don't
like me but I said you know you you're
not calling for us you know we've had
more challenges in Belgium and France
and and and remember this was the big
the big incident incident says that that
gave rise to this this rhetoric but all
you need is in it you know EU passport
and you get to the United States with
without anybody asking many questions
and you know this is at it's very core
this is discrimination that's if you if
you ever wondered that whether you were
going to live in America where leading
politicians advocated discriminating
against other individuals on the basis
of religion you live in that country
that's who we are
now not us individually but as a country
and that's how we're viewed by other
countries and our Canadian cousins who
are doing so much more than we are in
the regard to resettlement of immigrants
and particularly Muslim immigrants are
taking all of their cousins let me just
add to that kind of we've been talking a
lot about the you know the details of
refugee resettlement or what we should
do about specific populations but kind
of just going off of your comments
Governor on what that kind of macro
risks are in the long term for this
country
i I don't think people are you know
people of any one particular country are
born exceptional and that's what makes a
country exceptional right the country
gets becomes great when it has great
and what made America great for a couple
of centuries is that it's been able to
project an image that attracts the best
and brightest from the entire world
right it's all the research that I you
know referred to in that video has to do
with the fact that no you know in the
u.s. we are a leader in you know high
tech and science engineering so that's
the area that we have a comparative
manager and create new product new
markets right but but a lot of those new
products new markets Nobel Prizes are
not from people who are born in the
United States but they happen to be
affiliated with the u.s. University
happen to be living here running a
business here right and now if you're
sending these signals that this is not a
welcoming place right we're going to
lose that talent right and the big risk
is maybe it's not next year the big risk
is not the security risk that happens
this year next year in Brussels or in
Paris or or in New York right the big
risk is in like in 20 30 years this is
going to show up in our economy okay let
me add one other thing to this and I get
myself in trouble with some of our
European cousins when I talk about this
but we also follow up in the United
States a very different model which is
not perfect but where it's a far more
inclusive model of culturally speaking
things like housing and housing patterns
are very different for Emma Gray's and
refugees in the United States than they
are in in Europe of this is by
definition even though we stumble from
time to time a much more open society
and accepting society and the integrated
society and so some of the some of the
treatment on a broad-based cultural
basis in some European countries that
emma Gray's and particularly Muslim Hema
Gray's have been subjected to is not the
norm in the United States even though
we're having a discussion about this
abnormal behavior is not the norm and
certainly not the norm in college towns
and university towns and and places that
are more likely to be inhabited by the
urban environment so I think that that
there's reason
to be very hopeful that our past
experience with immigration and refugees
is a good predictor of a better outcome
just as I think European experiences
with refugees and their and their
integration that has been reasonably
predictive of some of the shortfalls of
that system and just on your note on
your point
professor Mubarak attend that it will
show up in our economy in 30 to 40 years
there's also that aspect that we have
the international community that takes
our lead that invests in our country and
and if we start to close our doors to
what has traditionally been an open door
policy in our country what does that say
in terms of our relationships with the
international community community and
some of those refugees now and I don't
quite know what the policies are in a
place like Canada but I imagine what
Justin Trudeau that they're pretty open
a lot of that talent will then start to
go elsewhere like our competitor in
Canada right yeah and in fact I mean
it's been a great boon for countries
like Canada Australia the United Kingdom
right which offer many of the same
services such as if you're if you're an
English speaker those are the first set
of places that you think about right
so I remember after 9/11 there were this
visa mantas program that was instituted
that made it much more difficult for
foreign graduate students to come to us
universities especially in what they
call the you know sort of technically
skilled areas like physics and
engineering right where they might be
security risks and and post 9/11 for the
next few years Australian universities
British universities were very happy
they were getting much better much
better students and as soon as I know
America started projecting an
unwelcoming image right so the president
of France made an english-language video
which is blasphemous in French to do
saying that oh one inventory I'll tell
you what why do why uh why don't America
scientists come here right so similarly
Canada has instituted policies say okay
if you want to shift over
say from MIT to McGill right we're going
to make it easy and that's exactly the
right I mean if I was running those
countries that's what strategy I would
take as well because it's high-skilled
people technically technically able
people talented people that matter right
but I would but but I would still
underline what Governor Malloy said
which is that look it takes a lot more
than a video okay so now my wife and I
for the first time in our lives we've
considered leaving given given the
situation in this country over the past
year right
however like when push comes to shove
when we look at okay what are the
opportunities that UK universities are
offering me or European universities
offering me right it turns out the US
has a huge lead in this market right so
it's you know like it does push us a
little bit in that direction but not
enough to actually send us over the edge
right because America has made a bunch
of extremely smart decisions over the
last 56 years in the way that rewards
the talent has been set up here which is
why we have to make sure that this is a
short lived exactly experience week we
can we can overcome a short period of
this type of behavior but we can't but
we'll do real harm if we if we if we
keep it up too long yeah if you keep
pushing us at some point you probably
made it's comforting to know that that
we're in the hands of great leaders like
all of you sorry Chris you had a point I
have one more visual aid and it relates
to the the point that you made that you
know the US has traditionally been a
leader the u.s. has traditionally been a
leader in resettling refugees but if if
we abandon that role and we lose
influence and clout in international
forms at the UN and and in meetings with
the heads of other states we won't be
able to encourage other governments to
increase the number of refugees they
resettle I mean if our numbers drop down
if we have a president who turns his
back on an international agreement to
bring 110,000 refugees to this country
how
we sit down with you know Australia or
or Belgian or or maybe Canada I don't
know and say you need to resettle more
refugees when we aren't doing as much as
we can that will drive more refugees to
desperation you've seen this horrible
photograph risking their lives trying to
cross the Mediterranean and drowning I
mean the impact that our decisions have
will be felt across the world and will
probably lead to loss of life so you
know we can't let this happen
and we settled in 2015 70,000 refugees
in 2016 it went up to 85,000 President
of the United States declared at the
United Nations at the end of 2016 that
the US would bring 110,000 refugees to
this country our current president has
now turned his back on that promise but
not Connecticut thank you one minute
stretch all right we're going to start
the second part and we'll keep it pretty
short I know where it's out of running
out of time but I think it's important
to discuss the recent the recent ban of
the Supreme Court decision so Justin yes
as I understand that the impact for
refugees from the recent Supreme Court
ruling on the Muslim ban states that a
refugee in the US can claim concrete
hardship but ultimately if they lack
connection as we spoke about before to
the United States the rule works against
them and in favor of the government's
need to provide for the nation's
security
can you please update us on where
President Trump's Muslim band stands in
the course right now what are the
possible outcomes and next steps for
both of your organization's I wrap em
and ILC okay so so milk along with the
ACLU we represent I wrap
in the case which is now called Trump
the I rap started
I repeat Trump which is a lot more fun
but they switch it when you get this
from court and so our case has been
consolidated with Hawaii's case and the
upshot is there are three provisions
that are now blocked to some extent so
you have and this is provisions of the
March sixth executive order a Muslim
Band 2.0 so you have section 2 C which
blocks the entry of all nationals from
not all blocks the entry of nationals
from six particular cliques Muslim
majority countries and then you've got
two parts of section 6 which are
specific to refugees so section six a
suspends the United States refugee and
admissions program for 120 days and and
it blocks the entry of any refugees for
those 120 days and then a separate
section of subsection of six cuts the
number of refugees purports to cut the
number of refugees who may be admitted
this fiscal year from the 110,000 that
was because that Chris referenced
earlier 250 thousand so one kind of
unique aspect of of federal law having
to as refugees is that before every
fiscal year the president sets the
number of refugees who may be admitted
in the coming fiscal year so President
Obama said that one hundred and ten
thousand there's no provision in the law
for that number to be changed
retroactively Lee nonetheless that's
what President Trump purported to do
cutting it to 50,000 so the Supreme
Court's opinion from Monday basically
said that those three provisions can be
enforced except as to individuals who
have some kind of bonafide connection to
an American individual or entity and so
there's a fair amount of confusion about
what that might mean but the upshot I
the upshot of what it should mean is
this basically if you were going to come
in if like someone anyone who was set to
come in in the next three to four months
from either one of the six countries or
as a refugee should still be able to
come in because virtually all of them
not all but virtually all of them
already have a connection to
in American individual or entity so if
you're from one of the six countries
you're coming here if you're coming here
on a visa they're virtually all visa
categories require a connection to the
United States already so every immigrant
visa there is an American citizen or
green card holder who's petitioning for
their relative to come every employment
based visa there is an American employer
who is petitioning every student visa
there's an American University who is
attached to that you know the folks who
are going to get left out in the cold
are going to be tourists from these six
countries who don't have a connection to
United States turns out we don't give a
lot of tourist visas to these six
countries anyway but nonetheless there
are going to be people who are affected
and you know maybe folks who win the
diversity lottery which is you know
total of what 10,000 people a year
worldwide sort of in an ER Lottery and
can get a green cards come to United
States
but otherwise if you're from one from
the six countries you probably already
have a connection when it comes to
refugees same thing as Chris was saying
these resettlement agencies know well in
advance who's coming and there are you
know the refugee resettlement pipeline
is as we've talked about tonight you
know two three five years long and there
are people at various stages of this
right and so there are enough folks who
are at the end who now have a connection
to an agency like Chris's organization
and others that that they should be
allowed to come in during the next four
period notwithstanding the court's order
similarly even even if they're not all
the way at the end there are lots of
other categories of refugees in the
pipeline that have a connection to the
United States so you know that there are
some 50,000 Iraqis refugees who have a
connection to the United States because
they're being persecuted because of
their faithful service to the United
States military or United States
contractor during the invasion and war
in Iraq there are some 10,000 Syrian
refugees who are in a program that
requires them to have United
states-based relative and so and there
are other such categories
that of of refugees who as a categorical
matter have the connection to the United
States and so the practical effect of
the court's ruling is that if you were
99 percent 90 whatever some huge
percentage of the folks who would have
gotten in in the next three or four
months anyway are going to come in they
should be unaffected but and so for that
reason when you think of it that way
it's kind of hard to understand how
Trump can claim victory as he did right
on the other hand think about it this
way these six countries have 180 million
Nationals combined there are roughly 65
million refugees in the world right now
there's some overlap but let's say more
than 200 million people in the world
right now are banned from entering the
United States the next three to four
months some 97% of them are Muslim maybe
actually no that's not true 97 percent
of the hundred eighty or Muslim the
refugees are I think it's between 70 and
80 percent Muslim but the vast majority
of them are Muslim two hundred million
Muslims are now banned from the United
States and that's why you have a lot of
Muslim organizations in particular
saying are particularly upset by this
because we now have an immigration
policy in this country for the next
three to four months in which under
which 200 million people are banned
because of their religion or because
they are associated with people of a
particular religion because they happen
to be at the same country and so in that
sense you can understand why II call his
claiming victory because it's never
actually been about banning people like
actually keeping people out it's been
about telling his base that he banned
Muslims because that's what he promised
he was going to do I mean the whole
thing it's never made sense right like
the you know this the seven countries
were chosen not because they actually
pose a particular risk they were chosen
because they were on a list that
pre-existed of it's too complicated to
get into but basically he could blame it
on Obama and say you know the Obama
administration said these countries are
dangerous and so that's why I'm doing it
not because they're Muslim but that's
like we know that's not true because
Rudy Guiliani said it's not true right
thank God for Rudy Giuliani
because like he sort of links all of
this together but so that's where the
case is right now is that the upshot is
the president gets his Muslim ban he
gets to ban 200 million people who
aren't going to come in anyway but in
nonetheless Costa claims victory we get
you know the people who were going to
come in we should be able to to help
most of them get in and then in the fall
the you know over the summer we'll be
briefing the case on the merits because
the court said in addition to sort of
partially lifting the stet the
injunctions they also said that they
were going to hear the cases on their
merits and so we have another round of
briefing to do over the next two to
three months and then in the fall in
October actually there will be oral
argument at the Supreme Court where
we'll argue and Hawaii why are you and
the Solicitor General will argue who's
the lawyer for the government who are
using the supreme court and then the
Supreme Court will decide something you
know I think that there's a decent
chance by then that they'll say the
entire case is moot because you know the
whole point of the band was to let the
government do this study to make sure
that you know the vetting procedures are
adequate and that those studies will be
done by the time the Supreme Court hears
the case the bans will be over because
by their own terms they only last 90 to
120 days and so I think that there's
some chance the Supreme Court will just
duck the issue entirely say it's all
moot but meanwhile and this gets back to
a question that I was asked earlier what
sort of impact does all of this have on
refugee policy and and you know in
particular as it relates to Connecticut
as I mentioned before every fiscal year
the president gets to say how many
refugees get to come in and so in
September President Trump is going to
make his determination is how many
refugees you know I think the actual
wording of the statute is something like
the number of refugees who
who whose entry would be in the best
interest of the United States or
something like that and so you know
historically over the last few years
we've you know resettle between seventy
and eighty thousand refugees but you
know although President Trump can't
legally cut that number after the fiscal
year begins like it is up to him to say
what the number is for next year and
year after in the year after and you
know Congress consults their this
consultation process that's required but
the ultimate decision is the president's
and so I think that's obviously a
concern because President Trump doesn't
seem to be in favor of refugees and
refugee resettlement and so that's the
that's what's next is you know what he
sets that number at and then whether or
not there's any way we can sue them over
it yeah so that's sort of where we are
right now I just have a quick question
and anybody else can add to this are you
working with big corporations like
France and Starbucks announced that they
would employ I think a hundred thousand
refugees after after the Muslim travel
Danna I think other companies are
following suit how are big corporations
helping move this forward and helping
sort of mitigate some of some of this
resistance towards refugees what I'm in
the litigation I can talk about the
litigation I think Beckham might be a
better position to talk about or others
and sort of beyond that but you know
certainly in the litigation we've had an
unbelievable response from corporate
America in in the form of amicus briefs
which is where it's a friend of the
court brief where anyone can sort of
weigh in with the court and say like
here's our view of like what you may be
overlooking or what you may not properly
be valuing you know at the at the Fourth
Circuit we had a tech companies amicus
brief that was signed by like some 200
major corporations Google Twitter you
know like I actually tweeted something
went right after the the darwish case
when we file it about the JFK folks me
JFK I tweeted something about like hey
if you want to get in on the fun you
know me kiss briefs or do whatever and
then like Twitter emailed me it was like
hey we want to do it when make his brief
that's pretty cool
but yeah I mean Becca do you want to
have anything to add about yeah I mean I
think it's just it's all the reasons
that the professor Mubarak was
discussing I mean you put up like eBay
Google and I forget what the third one
that's all okay
ah that's the electric cars right um
that's pretty safe yet the only car on
or more than the future um when they
lower the prices but you know I think so
like corporations these things I often
don't agree with but they're they're
very efficient and they understand that
we need refugees and immigrants to
continue coming into this country for
them to continue to innovate and turn a
profit and generate new products so I
think we found that in a variety of ways
you know both not just as signing off on
the litigation but like Airbnb just
launched a platform where if you're a
refugee and immigrant and you're
stranded at an airport or you need a
temporary place to stay you can do that
through the Airbnb platform and they're
reimbursing the hosts for allowing
people to stay there so there's all
sorts of really amazing ways that I
think corporations have stepped in to
offer their particular service in
service of this particular humanitarian
issue and sometimes it's in their
interests i I sit on a council on the
feature of global migration with the
World Economic Forum another those
people and so they in that councilor
there's a topic in that council there's
I mean there's members from the
government but I suspect you're very
impressive people that have had a chance
to now learn from and talk to and so
Western Union has one of their
executives on the council and because
you know allowing for disallowing
migration is really central to their
business right Oracle has an executive
there because you know they're really
reliant on cross-border movements of of
talent right so these guys can be
powerful allies that we should be trying
to take advantage of and make yourself
right well I'm going to ask one last
question and first of all I want to
thank you all for being here again but
if there's one thing that you
can recommend that we can do as
attendees of this and as citizens and
residents of this country in this state
to move the needle forward to help the
dialogue move forward what would that be
so maybe one point each don't get
distracted by shiny objects that's hard
great I would say we have to work on
that one that's generally true yes I
would encourage you all to have
difficult conversations especially with
white people about immigration and
immigrants and why they should care and
why they if they're against either there
they're wrong so it would be great for
us to move the conversation from
thinking about the security risks of
refugees because I don't think that's
actually the big issue to like what
their economic characteristics are we
should be thinking about these people as
economic migrants and honestly you know
I showed you you know I said things
based on a lot of data that we have on
immigrants we really don't have great
information yet on refugees and that's
that's not just refugees into the US but
large refugee populations that are in
Lebanon or or in Bangladesh at the
Bangla NMR border right and we need to
gather much better information on what
the economic characteristics are you
know these guys pause elected do they
have lots of assets do they have lots of
human capital right and that's you know
we should be thinking about the
opportunities there as opposed to just
the cost
please do not call refugees economic
migrants please don't there are huge
political and legal implications for
doing that thank you
similar adjustments of suggestion I
would say you know I I spend most of my
time preaching to the converted so what
I'd like for you to do is find people
maybe groups of people large groups of
people relatives friends who are not
convinced that we should be resettling
refugees and invite bush or me
to speak to them all right pusher oh
yeah yeah of course okay and so the she
said like um don't offer to be to ask us
any questions suppose else we're
accepting any questions this is what she
wanted to perfect well thank you thank
you again to our pound so we can give
them a big special thanks again to Yale
McMillan's Maryland for helping us
pursue together thank you so much and I
just want to be quickly to point that
beacon and main will be hosting many
more forums on various types of topics
and issues that affect our daily lives
socially and economically so please if
you haven't done so already sign up on
our mailing list you can learn more
about us and upcoming events at beacon
in Maine org we are a small state in
Connecticut with a big heart and a
tremendous amount of intellectual
[Applause]
[Music]
you